good afternoon it wasn't the scholars
after lunch it was a little bit of a
clogged elevator so that's true we had
the clever idea of taking the stairs and
I'll be aspirating as I taught before
you Mitt Romney has decided not publicly
to discuss his religion during this
campaign he is not running he notes as
pastor in chief he does not want his
church appropriated as a political
football either for his sake or for it
his silence is understandable although
opinions range at lunch and elsewhere
this afternoon about the prudence of
that strategy though more restrained
than in 2008 suspicions of Romney's
religion is alive and well file the
Romney camp remains silent on the matter
the public nonetheless one does want to
know something of what makes a potential
presidential a potential president tick
the nation since its beginning has
labored erratically to separate church
and state but it has not succeeded in
separating religion and society the
public seeks answers where it can get
them people who look for how Mormonism
me of shape to mr. Romney commonly look
at the movements theology often they
would do better to look at its history
to which Mormons themselves often give
priority this is a point the times as
David Brooks picks up on drawing
recently from a biography to trace the
Romney family version of the nineteenth
and twentieth century Mormon exodus
prior to MIT this was a for generation
saga beginning in the 1840s laced with
mob attacks pillage exile without
recompense from Illinois and then from
the United States itself church leaders
later called the Romneys two successive
colonizing assignments in remote parts
of Utah Arizona than Mexico attended by
poverty mal nourishment and primeval
living conditions in each circumstance
and generation the Romney survived
sometimes barely then recovered
flourished and were again called by
church authorities to new colonies else
they were banished to fresh from their
homes by hostile neighbors their
property forfeit only to move and to
prosper again by 1907 the family owned a
large and thriving ranch in Mexico where
mitts father george was born in 1912
when George was five Pancho Villa and
his revolutionary compatriots
confiscated the family property and
through its owners out penniless again
the Romneys fled to California then
drifted to Idaho Utah where they built
yet another fortune although Mitt Romney
experience none of this hardship
directly he is like a Jew who did not
live through the exodus yet is still
shaped by it character can take
generations to form Mitt Romney has
character flaws doubtless in his line of
work observers will find them or will
invent them but as David Brooks points
out his flaws are not the type
ordinarily associated with the soft and
bloated rich basking in their ease and
luxury Romney's salient traits do not
derive from his wealth rather his wealth
derives from his Mormon families
relentless will to rise and Romney
himself put it well before as he himself
put it well before his political days
Romney's are built to swim upstream
along with political philosophy and
talent then character and ones record in
enacting one's principles in public
service is a more apt criterion than
theology as one considers a candidate it
would be pleasing to see the retreat of
religious prejudice in the political
sphere but surely some suppose a Mormon
worldview so important and private and
so important in the formation of a young
Romney would bear some influence on how
a candidate sees the world and thus
potentially on how he might act as
president of the united states on the
public's behalf reporters and pundits
and vicarious rivals pose questions
earnest or otherwise can we trust a guy
who believes in angels and gold plates
and wears funny underwear to be making
decisions about Iran and nuclear
brinkmanship should a person who
believes he's going to inherit his own
planet one day be influencing the budget
for NASA this sort of question is
generally posed either in fundamental
ignorance of modern Mormonism or as
political chummy bloody rhetorical meat
thrown into the political water to
embarrass the candidate and attract the
Sharks this level of query also lacks a
feel for Romney's own way of blowing
Mormon and for his personal history as a
Mormon lay leader as a private religious
practitioner Romney has never been a
historian nor a theologian nor has he
much engaged the esoteric lore to be
found in Mormon folk culture his life as
a latter-day Saint Bishop and state
president was pastoral and pragmatic as
an administrator as a solver of
practical problems as a builder of
community and interfaith relations as a
resource to those in difficulty as a
counselor to those in grief other sorts
of questions when sincerely raised are
more plausible would a president Romney
be obligated to follow Mormon leaders
making national policy for America if we
have time later we could discuss that
but in a word no though the world's and
the nations media will would be on the
job looking for any whisper of such
relationship it goes contrary to
Romney's way of thinking and being and
his track record in public office
already and it goes contrary to of
so very public and firm these days LDS
Church policy another example of a
question that is of the sort that's
perpetually being asked since Mormons
characteristically believe in the
possibility of personal inspiration
would president Romney await and claim
revelation for every significant policy
decision the answer is probably not
difficult like many US presidents Romney
is a praying man such a habit is apt to
influence around the presidency as it
did the Romney governorship prayer
presumably occurred and it may have
affected his attitude in pursuing his
business or his professional
responsibilities but this was away from
public view it has been michelle bachman
and miss yours Perry Santorum and Cain
not the Mormon candidates nor so far as
i know mr. gingrich who have recounted
to audiences that God encouraged their
presidential candidacy 'he's as an
example of the prospects imperil of
trying to diagnose romney's prospective
or retrospective policy views in
relation to his church's theology i will
explore for a moment the idea of
American exceptionalism a version of
which Romney espouses not until Ronald
Reagan's 1980s did the term American
exceptionalism come to be used with
anything resembling the meaning
expressed by the current Republican
candidates the concept however has deep
american roots john Winthrop's famous
1630 sermon about aboard the Arabella in
effect renewed the Abrahamic covenant
between God and a chosen people brought
to a chosen land their incipient Puritan
community was to be a city upon a hill
said Winthrop it must become a light
shining abroad to the nation's forming
an example and signaling that God's hand
was upon New England so chosen was this
land that a century later Jonathan
Edwards discerned it as the
likely future place of Christ's second
coming the subsequent american century
saw the rise of a new experimental
different sort of nation possessed of an
exuberant sense of freedom and innocence
and a destiny that was more and more
manifest to continental occupiers
abraham lincoln despite his brooding
described the united states as the last
best hope of Earth in some the idea of
America as a unique place with an unique
mission has long held sway during the
last 30 years American politicians have
adopted the term American exceptionalism
which has come to mean and popular
parlance that the United States is not
only different from the superior to
other nations it is the natural leader
of the free world by one recent count
posted in The Huffington Post references
to this term in print media increased
from two in nineteen eighty-two roughly
3000 last year the idea that America is
chosen is also evident in Mormon thought
reprising the Hebrew Bible's predominant
motif the opening narratives of the Book
of Mormon not as I learned last night
the musical tell of a prophet and his
family who centuries before the birth of
Christianity were let out of a hardened
corrupted Israel about to fall to
Babylon and into exile this Prophet Lehi
was to be led to a land that God had
prepared for them a land of promise
which is choice above all other lands
prophecies in the unfolding story seemed
to seem specifically to allude to
America's future to the travails of
Lehigh's hurring descendants to the
eventual arrival of Gentiles who by
God's might emerged from their own
captivity and were lifted in the new
world above all other nations the
ancient prophet pronounces that there
shall be
there shall none come into this land
save they shall be brought by the hand
of the Lord wherefore this land is
consecrated unto them whom he shall
bring and if it so be that they shall
serve him according to the commandments
which he has given it shall be a land of
liberty unto them wherefore they shall
never be brought down into captivity
there shall be no kings upon the land
The Book of Mormon suggests that a
special burden is placed on the
inhabitants of America to obey God's
commandments proclamations by Joseph
Smith reiterated these themes he added
that the millennial New Jerusalem is to
be built upon the American continent and
he pronounced the enduring Mormon belief
that the United States Constitution is
itself an inspired document later Mormon
leaders have extended these teachings in
the mid twentieth century in the face of
severe communist threat Ezra Taft Benson
about whom Jan ships spoke earlier this
morning who was once Dwight Eisenhower
Secretary of Agriculture and later
President of the United States went so
far as to speak of America as God's base
of operations Canada Mitt Romney argues
that Barack Obama's alleged lack of
belief in American exceptionalism is
leading the nation to decline and that
this danger should define the coming
election we have a president now says
mr. Romney who thinks America is just
another nation with a flag President
Obama seems to think that we are going
to have a global century an Asian
century Romney's own foreign policy
contrasts sharply I would be guided by
an overwhelming conviction that this
century must be an American Century
where America has the strongest values
the strongest economy in the strongest
military an American Century means a
century where America leads the free
world and the free world leads the
entire world unlike our current
president I will never apologize for the
United States of America there is room
in mr. Romney's vision of the coming
century for Providence this is a time he
says where America has got to return to
principles that will keep us the hope of
the earth remember Lincoln and The
Shining City upon the hill that biblical
metaphor that Winthrop called upon that
light shining from that shining city has
dimmed over the last three years and I
will help restore yet and as another
example of the sorts of questions that
are put to what I'm speaking about I had
a reporter called last week from Reuters
asking about mr. Romney's language about
restore I will restore America I
understand that Mormonism that the
restoration is a key element in Mormon
thinking is it possible that there's any
link there Romney continues God did not
create this country to be a nation of
followers America is not destined to be
one of several equally balanced global
powers America must lead the world or
someone else will and he has said
elsewhere it's entirely plausible that
someone else will not be nice people now
is it possible if only at an unconscious
level that Romney's views of America's
proper role in history is tinged with
his Mormon sensibilities it is of course
possible just as it is possible at
President Obama's religion or his
parents divorce or his Hawaiian
background or his experience in law
school are strands that inform the way
he thinks but the limitations on this
observation and hints
many of the questions as posed the
limitations on this observation or many
and severe his religion cannot be
responsibly used to casually assess much
less to predict Romney's political
decisions if he were to become president
one limitation is the difficulty of
psychoanalyzing anyone even on the
nearby couch much less a public figure
based on press reports from afar a
second limitation is that as we have
noted American exceptionalism has roots
and to dating Mormonism if there exists
a Mormon current in Romney's embrace of
exceptionalism it is an eddy in a wider
stream other Republican candidates
professed versions of exceptionalism
with or without God a third limitation
is that Romney is a complex figure and
Mormonism but one stream informing his
makeup his trumpet of exceptionalism
might derive from his personal
competitive drive his faith in
capitalism or his secular patriotism as
readily as his religion a fourth reason
for caution in assigning religious
influence to Romney's thinking is that
Mormonism itself is complex its notions
of American exceptionalism are evolving
and ambiguous bearing dominant and
recessive genes in the Book of Mormon
America is a land of promise until it
isn't the narrative tells of recurrent
departures from peoples and lands grown
degenerate in affluence arrogance
injustice and lust for war there appear
in the book a long series of promised
lands and peoples who succeed or fail to
live into their chosen roles the
overarching prophetic promise is one of
demise and destruction if the nation
should lose its moral fiber moreover
chosen rarely means
exclusive but instead chosen for a role
chosen for a mission as one Book of
Mormon prophet has God saying know ye
not that there are more nations than one
know ye not that I the Lord your God
have created all men and that I remember
those who are upon the Isles of the sea
and that I rule in the heavens above and
in the earth beneath and I bring forth
my word unto the children of men yay
even upon all the nations of the earth
furthermore a central preoccupation of
mormonism for the past 40 years amidst
its vast international growth has been
how to shed its American presumptions
and to function in diverse cultures of
the world it has been almost 20 years
since most Mormons lived in the United
States Mormon growth predominates in
such areas as Africa and South and
Central America and this is contributed
one might guess to Mormon authorities
urging us lawmakers to show compassion
in formulating immigration policy what
any single Mormon politician might
deliberately or inadvertently extract
from this complex religious heritage as
it applies to practical political policy
is neither obvious nor inevitable
Mormons are not made from cookie cutters
as the new Mormon ads that have surfaced
in Times Square attempt to remind us the
mere presence on the national stage of
figures such as worse orrin hatch Jon
Huntsman and Harry Reid should help make
the point none of this lends itself to
easy assignment of Mormon thinking to
Mitt Romney's philosophy of America's
exceptional place in past and future
history as a final point we should know
that Barack Obama despite his critics
also has spoken of American
exceptionalism his version is not based
on our military prowess or our economic
dominance Americans says the president
have a core set of values that are
enshrined in our Constitution in our
body of law
our democratic processes in our belief
in free speech and equality that though
imperfect are exceptional the United
States is to be a nation whose true
strength dirac comes from the enduring
power of our ideals democracy Liberty
opportunity and unyielding hope and
above all a place of ceaseless
innovation and an abiding sense that
anything is possible I believe in
American exceptionalism declared Obama
just as I suspect that the Brits believe
in British exceptionalism and the Greeks
believed in Greek exceptionalism there
is considerable overlap on the
admiration between these two candidates
of the American Constitution and the
values that they hold but there are
sharp differences in emphasis and it is
worth noting that one could extract from
Mormon history and teachings and
scripture right reasons for supporting
either mr. Obama's were mr. Romney's
understanding of what makes America
special so take home message enough
already with religious prejudice history
is more important than theology and
character formation more important than
doctrine in anticipating any influence
Mormonism might wield on a Romney
presidency and finally the idea that
religious worldview might inform how a
potential president would think about
the world is not a silly notion
intrinsically as one among other
influences but we would do well to be
wary of inaccurate simplistic and
confident diagnosis of any such
influence religion may inform but it
does not presage this candidates
political choices thank
you